Speaker 1: So we have a voicemail number
that you can call any time. That number is
two one nine two. David P. Here is a caller really
mad. This, by the way, the San Antonio TROL.
He's mad at me again about things I
haven't actually said about vaccines.
Take a listen to this PAC man.
Speaker 3: I wanted to call and talk
to you about the vaccines that you got super
guilty, did you? OK. And I'm telling the other
trolls in your audience to go ahead and get it.
And I have a bone to pick with you about this.
I think that an issue like moving the
country past coronavirus is something
that should easily should be able to not
unite us. But no, you want to divide us by it,
by making issues, thumbing your nose at
the other side for not getting the vaccine.
Speaker 1: No. In fact, on this show, I've
made it clear we need to figure out ways
to just get people to want to get vaccinated.
Just just insulting or attacking. I don't know
what show this guy's watching, but his thing is
he always calls me and argues that things I've not
said were really, really bad idea to say there's
Speaker 3: better ways to do it. There's
reasons people are on the fence about it. Yeah.
And there is better ways to bring them over
to the side of vaccines than mocking them, calling
them dumb and call them unintelligent just so you
could line your pockets and get those clicks.
What's this guy talking about? Not everything
has to be Democrat and Republican, but
Speaker 1: no, that's true. It's just
overwhelmingly Republicans that don't want to
get vaccinated. The one factor that most predicts
whether you will or won't get
vaccinated is are you a Trump supporter?
That's the number one slice that we find. I mean,
it's not me making it that way.
Speaker 3: This issue shouldn't be
political and you have done nothing but politicize
it. You are just as bad as these morons on the
right saying it's going to turn you into a pink
zombie. It's going to alter your DNA into some
mind controlled robot. That is abidance. You know,
Speaker 1: me saying we've really got to figure
out a way how to get these people vaccinated.
That's the same as saying the vaccine will
change your DNA. That's that's a weird assertion
Speaker 3: by history, by fingertips. You're just
as bad as these people. Are you saying that the
government should kick down your door? And and
Speaker 1: I've never said that
Speaker 3: force people to take
the vaccines that insanity never said and telling
people they're morons for not taking this. There's
better ways to do it. And most people don't
believe the nonsense on the far right about this.
Speaker 1: All right. So anyway, that's the San
Antonio troll. He will he will levy blistering
critiques against things I've not actually
said. On the show, we are going to talk about
the Provincetown cluster, a lot of misinformation
about the Provincetown covid situation. We will
talk about it on today's bonus show. We will
talk about why Jordache drivers are on strike.
I am boycotting Jordache. I will tell you why on
today's bonus show. And we will also talk about
the settlement of the Zoome bombing lawsuit for
85 million dollars. All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at
Unidentified: Join Pakman dot com.